Let's now talk about a little bit about Dr.
Anthony Foushee.
Months ago, the Trump administration made
it clear, as I just told you a few minutes
ago, they're moving past coronavirus.
They're done with Corona virus, at least from
the standpoint of talking publicly about the
virus and the pandemic.
We saw the press briefings essentially eliminated
when Donald Trump wondered aloud about injecting
bleach and isopropyl alcohol, putting them
into the body, as he says, to treat coronavirus.
The press briefings stopped a couple of weeks
ago.
We heard from Dr. Anthony Fauci that he was
speaking to Donald Trump less and less frequently.
And this week, in an interview two days ago,
Dr. Fouchier confirmed he has not spoken to
Donald Trump at all in more than two weeks.
Remember, Dr. Anthony Foushee is the director
of the National Institute of Allergy and Infectious
Disease.
He's essentially the top infectious disease
doctor in the country.
He has made it very clear over the last week
that states that aren't ready to reopen really
shouldn't reopen.
He has made it clear that if states open and
businesses don't stick to the guidelines that
are established, it's going to go really badly.
Dr. Foushee said a few days ago, very specifically,
he would not go to Donald Trump's Tulsa, Oklahoma,
rally this Saturday.
That's a bad idea.
He wouldn't go to.
Any other events like it either, and now he
has confirmed that the last time he spoke
to Donald Trump is more than two weeks ago.
And even then, Trump only wanted to know about
what was going on with vaccines.
And this is because we know Trump is increasingly
obsessed with vaccines, not for health reasons,
but because he believes that a vaccine is
something he could take credit for to justify
his reelection in November.
The last time Trump and Foushee spoke, they
didn't talk about coronavirus exploding in
many states.
They didn't talk about cases, hospitalizations,
resurgence, spread.
It was just what's going on with the vaccine
because Donald Trump thinks that's something
he could use to get himself reelected.
So this is not an accident.
My friends, from the standpoint of the political
position of the Trump administration, the
corona virus pandemic is over and we are now.
What's that?
It's the the return to greatness or with rereads.
I forget with the stupid propaganda term Trump
came up with is something about greatness.
That's what Trump sees right now.
And Trump even said this week, you don't do
any more testing.
You won't find any more cases.
Problem solved.
Right.
Haven't you taken a look at the stock market?
Everything's great.
Now just stop testing and then we won't have
any cases.
How many Americans are going to die because
Donald Trump never took this seriously and
then stopped taking it seriously.
After only taking it seriously for a very
short period of time, how many Americans are
going to die?
Because Donald Trump, by even having a huge
rally, is implicitly signaling to his supporters,
you can gather in large groups.
Go ahead.
Listen, I'm having 10000 people at my rally.
You can go ahead and have 20 people over.
No big deal.
And, of course, then the spread will continue.
The president has not even spoken to the top
infectious disease doctor in two weeks.
And more Americans have now died of corona
virus than the number that died in World War
One.
There's all sorts of different metrics and
statistics that have been put together comparing
the death toll to all sorts of other horrible,
horrible things.
So Trump is trying to make Corona virus go
away by ignoring it.
It's you know, we can have that object permanence
conversation again about little kids, unfortunately.
And this is the real tragedy.
He's convinced tens of millions of Americans
to do the exact same thing.
Are we?
I've been speaking to friends in Florida,
friends in Arizona.
People are just mostly acting like everything's
fine.
Yeah.
You still have some people wearing masks and
staying home, but the virus doesn't need that
many people to gather to continue spreading
more and more quickly.
Six U.S. states are seeing record highs in
cases.
Twenty U.S. states are seeing increases.
The six big culprits are Florida, Texas, Arizona,
Oklahoma, Oregon and Nevada.
In terms of percentage growth, and they have
had their highest single day spikes in the
last week.
Now, in some cities within these states, things
are so bad that bars have started to close
even though they're allowed to be open.
So there's a place in Jacksonville, Florida,
Lynch's pub.
So many of their employees and customers got
coronavirus that even though they're allowed
to be open, according to the Florida guidelines
that are currently in place.
They said we have to close because this is
absolutely crazy.
So we are now in the please disperse, move
along.
Nothing to see here phase of the pandemic,
except much like in the Leslie Nielsen movie
Naked Gun.
Explosions are going on in the background
while they say.
Move along.
Nothing to see here.
Step back.
Nothing has been resolved.
The broken health care system hasn't been
fixed.
The underlying economic fragility of our system
has not been addressed.
We are not any better prepared for the next
outbreak.
We still aren't testing enough.
We have no plan to prevent a second wave.
If we even get a break between waves one and
two, literally nothing has been fixed.
Although fortunately, some states and we're
going to hear about one state in a moment.
Some states are doing enough to modestly keep
things under control.